what I didn't expect I thought I was
gonna get all this love like you know
people were gonna agree with me and
instead I just got this unending torrent
of hate online which you know well about
and then one day I was at my barber my
friend Jess and she called David over
and she took out the mirror and she said
you better look at this and I had lost
these massive chunks of hair literally
to the point where at one point it was
about 40 percent if not more I was
spraying on my hair painting it on that
why I left the left video that I know
you've seen because we've done some
panels together about it was in the
midst of it when I was not only just
spraying on her but I was on this
experimental medication and I was broken
out and my head was oozing and i sweared
it's not it's not exaggeration I was
about to quit I was literally like an
hour away from quitting Candace Owens
the founder of the blex it movement and
I am thrilled that my friend Dave
Reubens book is finally out
don't burn this book which as you guys
know for me is extremely tempting
because when people tell me what not to
do I really want to do it but instead I
actually read this book I didn't burn it
and I'm super excited that I am the
person that gets to present this chapter
which is never surrendering to the mob
which is pretty much the story of my
entire career so Dave this is super
exciting for you this project I know
you've worked so hard on it locked
yourselves in many rooms let's jump
right into it yeah before anything else
I just I just have to say one thing
which is when I was figuring out the 10
people to do these chapters with and I'm
talking to my Associate Producer and
David and my whole team we're all
looking at number six like Candace is
taking six right yep Candace is taking
six all the other ones we debated we
moved people around but it was like nah
nah we know what's going on with number
six yeah and you know I appreciate that
because I do think I'm a big person I've
never never surrendering to the mob and
I have to say what's really unique about
this book is that it gives a lot of the
personal side to you which don't really
get because you're usually on the
interviewer and you don't talk much
about your personal life and it was
really unique to hear this experience
which I had never ever ever know
about and this is the struggle of what
you went through I think is really
incredible and you know me and my
husband were discussing in a couple of
days ago when we first got the book and
I was going to did we ever know that
Dave sort of went through this hardship
which I don't know if I should get the
details out yeah we by the well no well
good I'm going to assume that most of
the diehards bought the book already so
they know yeah when I first sort of said
hey lefties something's not right here
like let's be nicer let's be liberal
again and I did what I didn't expect I
thought I was gonna get all this love
like you know people were gonna agree
with me and instead I just got this
unending torrent of hate online which
you know well about and then one day I
was at my barber my friend Jess and she
called David over and she took out the
mirror and she said you better look at
this and I had lost these massive chunks
of hair literally to the point where at
one point it was about 40 percent if not
more I was spraying on my hair painting
it on that why I left the left video
that I know you've seen because we've
done some panels together about it was
in the midst of it when I was not only
just spraying on her but I was on this
experimental medication and I was broken
out in my head was using and i sweared
it's not it's not exaggeration I I was
about to quit I was literally like an
hour away from quitting I could not take
it and I don't know what got me to the
other side something just it just pushed
me through like you know everyone before
me and my family has had it a lot worse
than me and was I gonna let like some
hair loss you know get rid of me but I'm
proud to say it's all mine and Candice
as someone that doesn't surrender to the
mob I don't want to say what happened
but I might have gotten a haircut
yesterday just I'm not saying I did I'm
not saying I did or I didn't I'm just
saying my hair is a little shorter than
it was yesterday okay I don't want to
not I don't want anyone snitching on me
Garcetti already on a kite is up but
we've all been through that sort of
thing right like when you started coming
out you did that great video when you
were red pill black way back when coming
out as a conservative and did you expect
just to get love and then the next thing
you know you get some love but like the
crazy hate you know I would say the
thing that surprised me the most and
it's something I never forgot about
actually Charlie Kirk I guess so I've
had more of a vision that I was going to
be
very successful and gain a lot of
followers you've kind of had that sort
of that same vision - I didn't see it in
the beginning I was just sort of doing
what felt right and he sat me down and
he made me read an article of things
that can change in your life when you
gain a little bit of Fame and I read it
sort of you know okay this is good plug
into the back of your mind but I don't
know if this is going to actually be
applying into my life and you know now
my husband actually says to me a quote
he doesn't know which Beatle said it but
he's apparently they said Fame doesn't
change you it changes everybody around
you right and I think that's just such
an interesting quote so one thing that I
experienced jumping into this was I was
the same candidates I've always been
this Candice I've always been the
outspoken Candice they've been a little
different
I've always been convicted whether I was
convicted as a liberal in the thinking
this is exactly who I want to be and
helped my convictions
I was always the same person so to watch
people spin me into a caricature and
then I think the worst part was losing
family members that totally shocked me
when I was reading your chapter and
thinking about you know the shock and
you speak about someone who was
literally at your wedding or was invited
to your wedding invite them didn't
didn't respond to the wedding invitation
but yeah was invited to my way one
through the exact same thing I had
family members who didn't even respond
I mean honor my wedding with a response
you know because they I I was a
conservative so that was somebody that
you just you can't deal with anymore and
I think that is sort of one of the
biggest shocks I think of knowing that
you can be the exact same person and
rather than discuss an idea with you
you're just considered completely done
you're just completely barred from your
close families and your friends and
that's such a valid point when you're
giving your list of things for people to
just you know I love that the advice
that you give in in each chapter knowing
that your friendships are going to
change your friendships change a lot and
I can't even imagine how much your hip
step change hurts yeah they're probably
changing as we speak but but the other
reason that I wanted to have you on to
do this one is not just that you've
survived the mob like when people think
about the mob like the average person
they don't expect to be the number one
trend on Twitter and the Kanye thing and
have literally the Twitter moments you
know I think it called you far right or
all right or the rest of it
but but one of the reasons
I love you not having anything to do
with our public thing is that you and I
when we hang out otherwise like we
challenge each other the entire time
like it's not it's not fake like we have
argued about every freaking thing known
to man and it's like we don't hold it
against each other and I wonder what do
you think that is psychologically that
some people when you disagree with them
they want to mob you and what is it
about the other people that don't want
to do it because that's the people that
we're really talking to here like what
is it about us that yes do I think the
progressives are wrong about everything
am I worried about socialism and big
government or they of course I am but I
don't try to send a mob to destroy them
I will I want to expose their ideas
right I think it what is different about
us is that we genuinely like to learn
and we have a pursuit of uh you know we
wanted to pursue knowledge and and part
of that takes a tremendous amount of
humility if you're actually interested
in the pursuit of knowledge then you
have to be willing to accept that you
might be wrong right so when you and I I
love getting into a room with you
because sometimes I'm just saying stuff
to say stuff I don't even necessarily
believe it but I'm like I heard this
idea and I want to know what you think
about it I'm thinking of a time where
you and I did an event at some college
and I was pushing you on there's
something to do with gay marriage and
then you hit me back with something that
like you won up to me and we're like oh
I said you know I read somebody who said
that society begins to fall apart at the
very moment that gay people get rights
right so we're addressing rapidly oh say
that I didn't even necessarily believe
it I heard it and I wanted to introduce
it and to debate it and to hear what you
said and then you hit me back and you
said well then you said well then you
can make that same argument and say that
actually it really starts when women get
rights right and I said that's actually
a brilliant rebuttal to that so I'm
trying to learn and build and part of
that is being able to say something
right to actually say something and get
feedback and you're just one of those
people that you like to learn we like to
grow we like to build we can be wrong
it's okay to be wrong and that allow
people don't possess that humility so
it's interesting because one of the
things for you is you've dealt with like
the highest level versions of this like
every member of the media going after
you but not
just going after you in many ways going
after you because of your race like yes
of course it is what you say but if you
were saying the same things as a white
woman and this is just the perversion of
identity politics it's like they would
just say you're a racist and that's it
but then because you flip everything on
your on their head they feel that this
it's in many ways they're going after
you purely because of your race it's
it's really bizarre it's like almost
hard to explain yeah I almost present a
conundrum from them because they've sort
of been able to sort of holster
themselves on their high horses on this
idea that they're so accepting right and
then everybody else and you talk about
this in your book is a Nazi Ana racist
in the sexist and then you get someone
who's a black female agreeing with the
alleged Nazis and the everybody Hitler's
right and so they don't know what to do
with me because they what they do is
because it is essentially saying that we
go out because we need to defend people
like Kandace people that look like can I
seem to be defended and when someone
that looks like me says no thank you
it renders I'm immediately powerless
right they they don't know what to do
with it and it's a fun to me personally
it's a fun space to be in because I
almost demand that they think and that
they actually debate with ideas and
they're incapable of doing that because
they don't have any ideas they just have
anger and rage you know it's funny
because I remember you got married in
August and I was you know I do my
off-the-grid August and I had the whole
month you got married was it the 31st
you actually got married on the last day
of August yeah and I remember the whole
month I was like ah I'm gonna get I'm
gonna be off the grid the whole month
and then I'm gonna show up at the
Candace's wedding and there's gonna be
all like the public people there and I
know somebody is gonna screw me over and
tell me something about the news but
anyway that we which didn't happen by
the way
although somebody tried to I won't
mention I won't throw him under the bus
publicly but somebody tried to tell me
something but when we got to the wedding
David and I took a picture with you and
I posted it on Twitter or something and
then I saw all these people oh it's you
know the alt-right wedding and there's
the homophobe and the self-hating black
woman and blah blah blah and it was one
of those things where not only was the
wedding like one of the most fun
weddings I had ever been to but the
people that you had there were exactly
what America is there were evangelical
Christians there were gay people
straight people there were or that
Jews there were every mix and color your
husband happens to be white so half the
party was white half the part and no but
the idea that anyone would have cared at
any level I I had honestly one of the
most interesting conversations I've ever
had in my life was that night for about
an hour
I was extremely drunk I don't think he
was but with the priest I had such a
great conversation with the priest and
it was like man all of these haters that
would love to send the mob on any of us
and you know you you guys I'm sure had
to have some extra security there and
the rest of it it's like they they just
have nothing to do with anything
remotely close to the truth yeah you
know I briefly touch on my wedding I
mean just a couple of sentences in my
book and um I talked about that because
it did represent something really it
really does disrupt everything that the
Left breaches and everything that the
mainstream media narrative is when
people just come together and celebrate
love right they can't stand that because
it shouldn't work out I'm a girl from a
poor background my family's in poverty
or comes from more wealth you know his
family is more privileged I'm black he's
white I'm a woman he's a male another
this should work we've got gay people on
our way and got my lesbian cousins at
the wedding right none of this should
work but it should have just been an
instant war right are you gay are you
straight are you tall are you short and
that's not the way the real society
actually works and one of the things
that I always say is gosh this world
would be so much better if everybody
could just love off right and you talked
about that in your book why you make the
decision to sometimes occasionally log
off and participate in real life because
we actually do get along and that's that
that is something that I believe truly
that the left hates is us getting along
yeah what's your policy on the apology
because one of the things that I try to
put in the book is never apologize with
the only caveat being if you genuinely
do something wrong we've all apologized
in real life I apologize to David all
the time I mean we all have apologized
when it when it's right but I think one
of the mistakes people make is they
apologize when they're not sorry
actually or when they didn't do anything
wrong because they think that buys them
room they think it'll get them some cred
but really that never does and I've seen
you go after people on Twitter or get
into somewhere someone goes after you
and then every now and again I've seen
you try to take the upper you know
the knot the upper hand the the higher
road but what's your policy generally
related to apologizing when it when it's
relative to the public life yeah I
pretty much never apologize an issue my
public life what what you what you
realize very quickly is they want to
take you down they will interpret
everything to be wrong and here's a
perfect example of that when they took
out of context my comments when I was
talking about naturally talking about
nationalism right I'm gonna bring the
reason why didn't apologize is because
there was not a single person asking me
to apologize I thought that I was trying
to defend Hitler
it was disingenuous demanding the
apology in and of itself was
disingenuous if any person watched the
entire entire but you know the entirety
of a clip and you said hey Candace you
know you know I'm Jewish I saw the clip
and you know just really came across on
if you are Dennis Prager pick up the
phone it would have been entirely
different circumstance but as I said I
had you and Dennis Prager you know
defending me and then Prager University
defending me and because they knew that
dennis is one of your mentors I mean
forget about you and and they knew it
was foolishness and so if what I did say
was I could have worded it better right
you know not so not sleeping um you know
we came in on an overnight flight into
London and I worried it better if I had
known that four months later Busby was
gonna go back and find the video and
strip it of the question and just have
the sentences play absolutely but was I
sorry for what I said absolutely not
there was nothing nothing to apologize
for I was not defending Hitler and the
second you give them just a little bit
of rope they will hang you with it the
second they find out that you're
vulnerable and you care about your PR
and and they're gonna you know they're
gonna get you on this
you got to play that game forever so I
don't play it with them and if I
genuinely said something and then said
to myself you know wow that came across
really wrong it was a scene within me to
movement I was the first one who said I
don't support this at all and everyone
demanded an apology he this means you
support rape left and right hammered me
I didn't back down cuz I I knew what I
meant if you're gonna turf that to me
that you think I want women to get raped
you're being disingenuous right I am a
woman you know I don't want women to get
raped so I think establishing really the
terms of the apology are they actually
seeking an apology or they seeking Jimmy
Lee to humiliate you and the answer is
always they're seeking to humiliate you
when it comes to the left yeah what
would you say to the people this is what
I was
trying to get the chapter to really feel
at the end I wanted to give not the
public people that have chosen to get
into this game like for all the
headaches that it comes with and all the
great things to write like we have great
lives it's good we're doing what we're
supposed to be doing but for the people
that are that are I hate the phrase
regular people but for people that don't
choose this game but that one day it
will come for them because that's what
I'm trying to show people is it will
come for you one day because if you have
any flicker of an original thought one
day someone will use that against you do
you have any advice for like the average
person that isn't going to be out there
defending themselves on Twitter but just
like the tactics that they can use in
their own life to get some sort of not
just defense but to actually go on the
offensive with this as well honestly I
think it's important to stand up for
yourself even if you don't have a
platform or you don't think that you
have a big voice I think it matters
every single time I always stood up for
myself when I disagreed with things that
my professor said in college I would say
it was ridiculous
when I had was forced to take a feminism
101 course I stood up for myself because
what you really find with the left is
that it is you know the emperor has no
clothes on right so my teacher wanted to
give me a bad grade because she
disagreed with me and I was willing to
take it all the way to the head and have
her say why she just agreed with the
fact that I didn't hate men or why she
wanted me to say after right you know I
am a feminist on the board because I
disagreed with what she was trying to
teach me she doesn't want to do that
right because and that's really what it
is if they're not in a big group of
people they really have no clothes on
and I've learned that if it's not auntie
pho with sixty thugs they really have a
damper or has no clothes on so stand up
for yourself every single time and I'm
waiting for the corporation when they
hit them with these bogus discriminating
law discriminatory lawsuits to say I'm
not apologizing you know this is
ridiculous and I'm not going to pay some
exorbitant fee you know to some black
groups what it looks like I'm
dissociating myself from racism we need
to all start standing up for ourselves
if you're not over eAssist you're not a
sexist you don't apologize for being one
yeah the other version of that is with
the gays whenever somebody makes some
sort of loosely anti-gay remarks or joke
which is actually not anti-gay what do
you got to do you got to write a check
to GLAAD and then you're good to go
somehow you can pay your way out of it
how how bizarre so what wait
more thing for you because it really tie
this whole thing together I wanted to
mention this up top but right now you
were going through your own version of
standing up to the mob you sent out a
tweet that you want to paraphrase the
tweet or maybe you know it by heart
already at this point because you're
suspended for twit from Twitter right
now as we're taping it yeah I said to
the people in Michigan open their open
your businesses go to work you know
governor Whitner Whitner is out of line
police officers think she's nuts -
they're not gonna arrest ten million
people for going to work so and right so
okay so let's put aside the specifics
because actually you're a private even
though you're a public person you're a
private citizen you're not an agent of
the government you're you can say what
you want but Twitter basically took down
your tweet and now they have suspended
you so you haven't tweeted in like five
days you must be freaking out at the
moment or you're very you're probably
very happy actually but but but you're
not backing down because all you have to
do to get back on Twitter right is just
what woody what would you what do you
technically have to do at this point you
have to go through this process of
saying that you were wrong and you're
going to delete the tweet but I wasn't
wrong I'm allowed to say that even if I
wanted to say go out in protest that's a
constitutional right okay so if a
peaceful protest as in going to work is
considered something that you're not
allowed to say on on Twitter and we need
to be worried because we're very quickly
training towards what you see in a
communist society where you cannot
pratik the government I critique
critique you know a politician I
critique governor whitmer and I
encourage the people to peacefully
protest in their own ways and that is
something that the Facebook and Facebook
and Twitter are saying it's not okay
anymore because it's a risk to public
safety that's the language you see in
socialist and communist societies
disagreeing with the government is a
risk to public safety and it's not it's
absolutely not a risk to public safety
so I'm not backing down I filed an
appeal and I look forward to hearing
back from them I mean so as someone that
probably more than anyone else that I
know doesn't surrender to the mob I mean
how long will you allow yourself to be
in limbo because I know you want to get
your thoughts out there and everything
else I mean what if they just don't
respond to you which actually that would
be that would be their move right now
right like just let's just ignore her
you know and then she'll peter out
she'll disappear that's what they're
hoping
then I'll lawyer up you know I'm not
taking any prisoners this year and I've
been very serious about going out for
the tech companies I had a great phone
call actually a lawyer
two days ago talking about this and
saying that I think we need to get
serious about this we need to put
together a legal defense fund this thing
is getting crazier and crazier
and and they're widening the noun people
that they're trying to censor and you
know I've had issues with Facebook this
week as well
marking things as fake news fake news
assessments are being done by former CNN
editors for facebook lead stories calm
is run by former CNN editors of 20 to 26
years they're considered unbiased fact
checkers and you know all of this
foolishness the end of the day these
these tech companies have largely become
utilities and and for people like me who
I rely on the ability to get my voice
out that is my life that is my career if
you're gonna censor me because I said to
people to go to work I mean when are you
gonna start like finding parents for
telling their children to make their bed
I mean that's called being a responsible
citizen right I mean this is like crazy
stuff and the meanwhile you've got
people that are doing haircuts being put
in prison prisoners are being released
I'm in Twitter jail people can issue
threats on Twitter and say you know like
that former Sarah Joan New York Times
person canceled white people kill like
all that's good and if someone's go to
work bad it's just I keep telling people
I don't know if you saw the movie
idiocracy but I keep telling people
we're about a week away from whitmer or
gavin newsom here telling people to
water the crops with gatorade like
that's how stupid the whole thing has
become you know it really is well listen
Candis you truly like you are the living
example of this chapter you've done it I
know you will never surrender to them
and I look forward to seeing you on
Twitter one day but if not we'll do it
in real life how about that
that sounds go we can be people in real
life guys go out get the book if you
don't have it yet
and don't be like me and be tempted to
burn it just because he told you not to
that would be bad if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlists all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell